please please please they got a big shot
big show and I know why you're excited
tonight it's tomorrow is the big fight
everybody's been waiting for the big
Mayweather Pacquiao fight and it's so
nice after a week of violence and racial
strife that we could just sit back and
watch a black guy in a Filipino beat the
[ __ ] out of each other but no also this
is a historic day
turns out of a bunch of cops in America
blatantly murders them and you can
actually charge the bone ooh yes the
uber in Baltimore the prosecutor there
Marilyn Mosby charging six police
officers with the death of Freddie gray
including second-degree murder and also
the driver of the van got charged with
second-degree murder wow I didn't know
you could charge someone murder for
driving this this is very good news for
Baltimore and America and and very bad
news for Asians on the 405 I can't be
no but but I'm glad things have calmed
and not a moment too soon because the
protest you saw this we're spreading to
different cities and here in LA we were
hoping it didn't turn violent because we
do not have enough water to turn the
hoses on anyway you need that water sad
but of course you know the police in
Baltimore not happy about this coming
down from the prosecutor they saw the
head of the police union today said they
did nothing wrong as always infallible
do it by the book well they have their
own version of what happened they say
first of all Freddie gray was resisting
not being dead that's number one and he
may have been trying to frame the Cubs
by beating himself to death with a car
and the violent shaking that happened
him was because of the earthquake in
Nepal so you have to look at these
alternative versions
now on the bright side Hillary Clinton
gave a very strong very liberal speech
on this so I she's getting her mojo
going she called her yeah I'm in brass
she called for reducing the prison
population in America and a whole new
approach to policing in general she said
after her trip to Iowa she knows what
it's life to be thrown in the back of a
van and taken into a hostile white area
so but you know what Hillary Clinton no
longer the only Democrat in the 2016
race Vermont senator Bernie Sanders
through his yarmulke and of course
Bernie says his whole strategy is to run
as everything Hillary is not and as a as
a 73 year old socialist Jew from Vermont
he's everything everyone is not he why
can't we love Bernie I know and he could
make it anything Bernie says not a token
Kansas he says he is in it to win it if
he can just put together the coalition
that brought him to power in Vermont
craft beer enthusiasts
I scream billionaires and rural lesbians
he could win Berkeley but hey he's not
the real new star in America through the
real new star the hero is the Baltimore
mom who slapped her can American would
slap her kid they just just wow she beat
him so badly the cops gave her an
application
of course the people who really love
this for the Conservatives they love
these are the people of course you'll
love it when Bill Cosby tells black
people to pull up their pants that's
what they remember Bill Cosby pull up
your pants that's what they love on Fox
and Friends they were so excited about
this until someone explained that you
can't actually smack the black off a
person that's are we going back to the
owing now
I was enjoying this for a while I guess
it was a dream now I tell you the
Republican capacity to look away from
real problems and not see the cause
that's really there the Republican
congressman from Texas bill Flores he
knows why there's unrest in Baltimore
gay marriage I'm not kidding that's what
he said gay marriage you know what this
is no time to cram your pet causes into
a wholly unrelated event although I must
say I think things would be a lot calmer
if more cops smoke weed I'm saying
and Ted Cruz also said he knows the
problem Obama yeah he did he said Obama
has made decisions that inflamed
racial tensions rather than bringing us
together you know what Kanye was right
Obama doesn't care about black people I
tell you it is a reflex with the
Republicans it is blaming Obama it's a
reflex
last night Ted was making love to his
wife and it just wasn't happening and he
went Obama
you